these are the images President Joe Biden
hopes voters will remember on Tuesday as
they cast their ballots in midterm
Congressional elections supporters of
former president Donald Trump storming
the U.S Capitol Building attempting to
overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election a threat he says
remains today he refuses to accept the
will of the people
he refuses to accept the fact that he
lost
he has abused his power it was a dark
day in American democracy that Biden
claims opposition Republicans are poised
to repeat if the outcome of this latest
vote does not go their way trying to
succeed where they failed in 2020
suppress the right of Voters
and subvert the electoral system itself
that means denying your right to vote
and deciding whether your vote even
counts it's a decidedly dark message
from the normally upbeat Biden shaken by
the recent attack on house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi was struck
with a hammer in his home by a
right-wing extremist who claims he was
fighting against tyranny Biden says the
threats of political violence are
surging we can't allow this sentiment to
grow
we must confront it head on now
some conservative Republicans say
Biden's democracy speech is a desperate
attempt to deflect voter attention away
from crises of his own making Rising
interest rates food and fuel prices
America is going down a very dark path
right now
okay that that's
what I see inflation is really
concerning right now prices are just
soaring people can't afford anything
it's these economic concerns that are
giving Republicans a narrow Edge in
polling with more than half of all
voters identifying the economy and
inflation not threats to democracy as
the top concern for most Americans
heading in to Tuesday's congressional
election Kimberly helkin Al Jazeera the
White House